thanks very much for joining us my name
is peter bartlett i'm the associate
director of the simons institute for the
theory of computing
um we're a collaborative research
institute for theoretical computer
science
um uh we were established in in 2012
with a grant from the simon's foundation
and the institute brings together the
world's leading researchers in
theoretical
cs and related fields as well as the
next generation of outstanding young
scholars
to explore deep unsolved problems about
the nature and limits of computation
so it's my great pleasure to welcome you
to the
inaugural presentation in our
breakthroughs lecture series
highlighting substantial advances in the
field of theoretical computer science
and today um we're presenting the first
of of two breakthroughs talks that we'll
have this summer
um we're looking forward in the fall to
being able to convene the series
in person in kelvin lab
so before i introduce our speaker today
let me mention we'll have an opportunity
for
audience members to pose questions later
on so we ask that you hold your
questions until then and
use the q a function um in your zoom
window to do that
when the time comes all right so our
speaker today is
uh virginia vasilevska williams
virginia's the stephen and renee
finn career development associate
professor of computer science at mit
she holds phd from carnegie mellon
university and was previously on the
faculty at stanford
she's been a member of the institute for
advanced study she was a postdoctoral
fellow in computer science
here at uc berkeley her research is
broadly in the design and analysis of
algorithms
focusing on problems in in graphs such
as the shortest path problem
in matrices computing matrix products
which we're going to hear all about and
she's also interested in computational
social choice
her talk today is about her recent
breakthrough in the computational
complexity of matrix multiplication
it's entitled a refined laser method and
faster matrix multiplication
welcome virginia thank you peter
uh it's a great pleasure to join you
today and to tell you about this work
as you can see here i have a comic about
it it's a real comic that is an smbc and
it's titled mathematicians are weird so
we'll see how exactly how weird we are
all right
so i'm going to talk about matrix
multiplication um
so this is the matrix multiplication
problem it will matrix multiplication
was defined by cayley in 1855.
uh we're given two n by n matrices a and
b
whose entries are from some field think
of the real numbers the complex numbers
and so on
and you want to compute another end by n
matrix
c so that every entry of that matrix is
the following polynomial and the
input matrix entries so c i j
is the sum over k of a ik times b kj
and one of the main questions that we
want to answer is how many
operations over the field so the
products sums
divisions and subtractions do we need to
do in order to multiply two n by n
matrices
so uh this d people define this quantity
omega it's the exponent of matrix
multiplication
it is the smallest real number so that n
by n matrices can be multiplied in n to
the omega plus
plus little of one time so it's some
constant we know omega is at least two
because we have to output an n by n
matrix
and squared entries and it's also at
most three
because of the definition so in the
definition we see we
there's n cubed things we can compute
and we can get all the entries of them
of the matrix c so this is some number
and we want to know what it is because
it
it gives us if we can show that omega is
very small
that means we can have really fast
algorithms to multiply two matrices
all right why do we want to multiply
matrices so if you look at one of the
most long-standing best algorithms for
matrix multiplication by accomplishment
and winograd in
1987 they had over 3 000 citations which
is
amazing for a theoretical computer
science paper
so why is that most of the citations
they use this algorithm as a black box
so this is a black box over here
and what type of things can you solve
with matrix multiplication
so almost all linear algebraic
operations matrix inverse
rank determinant all sorts of stuff all
the linear algebraic things you can
solve
many graph problems like shortest paths
diameter regularity partitions all these
things
they can be solved with an algorithm for
matrix multiplication because you can
represent
graphs as matrices there's a lot of
applications in machine learning
and computer graphics and animation
basically everywhere you need to do a
change of coordinates you're going to
need to multiply matrices
and optimization scientific computing
constraint satisfaction and a bunch of
places where you might not even
know you may not even see why they
should be related to matrix
multiplication like context-free grammar
parsing
you can use fast algorithms to solve
parsing
and many many more applications so
there's so many applications it's a very
basic
problem and we really want to have a
very fast practical algorithm
for it today what i'm going to tell you
will not be about practical algorithms
it will be about what is the best
theoretically best algorithm we can hope
to achieve
and hopefully once we know what the best
theoretically best algorithm is we'll be
able to get
to a practical one as well
all right so here's a chart
of our knowledge about the matrix
multiplication exponent
omega through the years so
um up until 1969 the naive
and cubed algorithm was the best 1969
strawson
came up with an algorithm here's
strawson uh that had a better
running time into the 2.81 and
completely surprised everyone and in
fact the way he got his algorithm
was by trying to show that you cannot be
10 cubed
and while trying to show that he cannot
be thank you he actually beat it
so he got a better algorithm here then
a lot of improvements happened in
between and then in 1987 coppersmith and
winograd got this exponent
2.37548 and then
this running time stayed roughly the
same
up until 2010 when starters showed
that you can change this five four eight
into a three six nine
okay and then i showed that three six
nine can be made in a 2a8
and let go show that this 8 can become a
7
and what we show is that this 7 can
become a 6.
now this seems like a very tiny
improvement so why am i giving this talk
well it turns out that the reason
even though the improvement here is tiny
actually what we do is actually we
change the method
and the method for matrix multiplication
algorithms from here up to here was
exactly the same
and we changed it a bit and um
basically any you can apply this method
to many other tensors after that or many
other
ways to get matrix multiplication
algorithms and you can get better
exponents
all right so this is the picture my plan
for today
i'm going to spend quite a bit of time
introducing you to what matrix
matrix multiplication algorithms are
like about tensors and so on
because a lot of these algorithms they
have they have a lot of technical
background and i'll try not to go
too much into detail but i will have i
need some detail
then i'm going to tell you what the
laser method is
and then at the end i'm going to tell
you how we improve it
okay so here's the matrix multiplication
problem again we're trying to understand
what is this omega what is the best
running time we can get
in terms of the number of operations
over the underlying field so that we can
multiply two matrices we know that omega
is between
two and this number over here now um
but uh what we know now is that
this matrix multiplication problem is
actually about
the asymptotic rank of the matrix
multiplication tensor
so in the next few slides i'm going to
explain to you what the matrix
multiplication
tensor is and what this asymptotic rank
is
and then we'll see how that relates
to matrix multiplication algorithms and
why
matrix rank corresponds like in rank
corresponds to
algorithms all right so tensors
tensors have many guises okay
they can be viewed as three-dimensional
arrays
like this or they can be viewed as
bi-linear maps
so you take two vectors into a third
vector or they can be
viewed as tri-linear maps you take three
vectors and
make them into a scalar or they can be
viewed as multi-linear polynomials
and i'm going to take this last view so
let me
define tensors in terms of multi-linear
polynomials
so let x y and z
be sets of formal variables the x
variables the y variables and the z
variables and the tensor t is just a
tri-linear polynomial over these
variables
so the terms of the polynomial are of
the form x
i y j z k times some coefficient
alpha i j k these coefficients come from
the underlying field
like the complex numbers and they define
the tensor
okay so for us this is uh this is what a
tensor is going to be
what do these tensors have to do with
matrix multiplication
well every tensor defines a
computational problem
what is the computational problem you
have two vectors
x and y here and you have
uh p polynomials you want to compute
for every k from 1 to p you look at the
coefficient in front of z sub k
which is this term over here so the sum
over alpha i j k x i y j
and this is the polynomial we want to
compute so every trilinear
a polynomial defining a tensor gives you
a computational problem of computing a
bunch of bi-linear polynomials
okay so with this in mind
this is the matrix multiplication tensor
for multiplying
an m by s matrix by an s by t matrix
and it looks like this it has a very
nice
for symmetric form the sum over i j k of
x i j
y j k z k i if you look at the
coefficient in front of z
k i it is exactly the i
k entry of the matrix product of x and y
right so this tensor tells us
that the n squared uh polynomials or
m times t polynomials you need to
compute
are just the matrix product entries of
an m by s by
s by t matrix defined by x and y okay so
this is this
this is the matrix multiplication test
all right so
the matrix multiplication problem is
then a question about the asymptotic
rank of this tensor
now i have to tell you what rank is so
we know what tensors are they're just
trial linear polynomials in this talk
and we have to say what blank is
tensor rank tensor rank is just a
measure of complexity for of a tensor
and it is the natural generalization of
matrix rank
so to define a node just define what a
rank one tensor is
so rank one tensor is a tensor that can
be expressed
as the product of linear combination of
the x variables times the linear
combination of the y variables
times the linear combination of the z
variables so
the coefficient in front of x i y j z k
is a i times b j times c k
we often write this tensor as a tensor b
tensor c
if you look at matrix rank you would
just omit the z
k's the c k's and this product over here
and you get exactly
the notion of a rank one matrix
and the rank of a tensor is just the
minimum number of rank one tensors whose
sum is t
so this is just the unnatural
generalization of matrix
all right so uh right so
a polynomial a trillionaire polynomial
its rank is
is just a representation as a sum of
our of terms of this form
okay so if we look at the matrix
multiplication tensor it looks like this
so now i want to tell you how rank the
rank of this tensor
corresponds to matrix multiplication
algorithms
so it comes from this lemma
which i'm going to hand wave a proof for
in just a second
so the lemma says that if you have a
bound r
for the rank of the m by s by s by t
matrix multiplication that's r then we
immediately get a bound on the matrix
multiplication exponent omega
as three times log base m is t of r
how we do that with a recursive
algorithm it's easier to explain when m
equals x equals t in that case uh the
expression is like this
if the rank of m by matrix complete
multiplication is r we get this
expression for omegas how do you prove
this
you look at what the rank expression of
this matrix multiplication tensor would
be
if it were r it's just the sum of r
terms that are linear combinations of
the x
entries times the linear combination of
the y entries times the linear
combination of the z
entries so it gives us a representation
of the tension that looks like this
so what does that have to do with
algorithms well let's
try to use it to have an algorithm we
have an expression like this
for some matrix multiplication problem
that has constant size think of it as
2 by 2 by 2 by 2 matrix multiplication
then you can take larger matrices that
are n by n
and view them as two by two matrix
matrices whose entries are blocks
of size n over two by n over two more
generally
if it's m by m by m by m it'll view them
as m by m matrices with
blocks whose whose sizes are n over m by
n prime
so every matrix has you know you can
just block it like this and now you have
an algorithm
the algorithm is like this you look at
this expression
the rank expression and you see that
this is a linear combination of the
entries of the first matrix
which are now block matrices and you can
compute this linear combination in
linear size of a
linear time of the in the size of the
matrix because adding matrices is very
cheap
you can compute this linear combination
very cheaply as well you just
take sums of a bunch of sub matrices and
this m s and t they're constant size so
it's very fast
and then you can recursively compute
this product this
times this for everyone for l from 1 to
r
for all the r choices of products so you
get l
r products of linear combinations of
this matrix times the linear combination
of this matrix
and then you say well what do we have to
compute we want the
output matrix entry is exactly the
coefficient in front of z sub k i
the ik entry right so i look at what is
the coefficient in front of z sub k
i and this expression well it's the sum
of with
of c l k i times the p sub l the product
here
so it's again a linear combination and
linear combinations are cheap because
summing matrices take
n square time so the entire computation
depends on the number of recursive calls
which is r
and this is exactly where this log base
m of r comes from
from the recursive steps and this is
exactly how strassen
uh got his algorithm he showed the two
by two matrix multiplication
and that tensor has rank at most seven
now we know it's exactly seven
and so you get a bound for omega which
is log base 2 of 7
which is over here so strassen showed
the rank is small 70 so you get omega is
the most 2.81 which is log base 2 of 7.
pawn showed that the rank of 70 by 70
matrix multiplication is this horrendous
number
and then we when you took the log base
70 of this
he got 2.8 zero so less than omega then
the boundary strat
so he improved the bound now at this
point people stopped
analyzing fixed sites matrix problem
problems because this becomes unwieldy
and it's crazy to do by hand
so the method changed beyond that so
something else
started to be used so i'm going to tell
you roughly
what has been used since coppersmith
vinograd and beyond
so the way matrix multiplication
algorithms have been designed since 1987
um has had two two components the first
component is some algebraic identity
which corresponds to a rank
a representation of some small tensor
and then a method for analyzing these
identities
which is basically a method of getting a
matrix multiplication algorithm
out of these other tensors strassen
used the two by two matrix
multiplication tensor and
his identity is the rank representation
with seven
and the recursive approach from the
previous slide allowed him to bound
omega
after 1997 coppersmith winigrad had
defined the coppersman winograd tensor
and its powers
so they took the rank rank
representations of
the coppersmith winograd tensor and his
powers and
used something called the laser method
that straws and incorporation
and when aggregative devised roughly
around them
and got their bomb on omega since then
starters me and francois gao
we all used exactly the same method
but different powers of the coppers we
want to grab tensor for whatever power
means so define it in a bit
and what we do here is we keep the same
tensor
but we change the method so this is the
difference
before uh before the people were just
analyzing bigger and bigger tensors and
now we're keeping the
tensor the same and changing the method
all right good so at this point
i'm going to move on to telling you
what is the laser method okay
the laser method is an indirect way an
indirect method for analyzing matrix
multiple getting
matrix multiplication algorithms out of
other objects other tensors
it was developed by strassen who gave
it this name which is has a very
interesting
me i don't know how it anyway there's
some reason why it's called laser
let's move on so it was optimized by
coppersmith vinaigrette
and josh almond in 2019
showed that if a tensor has the property
the laser method applies
to it whatever that means then if you
can get omega equals 2
so the unoptimal matrix multiplication
algorithm out of that tensor
then the laser method will do it so in a
sense the laser method
is universal for a certain class of
tensors not all tensors but for a
certain class
if you wanted to get two
okay so let me go more in detail so i'm
going to tell you a little bit about
what these indirect approaches to matrix
multiplication
r so at a very high level
you take some algebraic problem p which
has some tensor associated with it
and you show how using a very good
algorithm for p
you can also solve matrix multiplication
basically it's just a reduction
technique
you reduce matrix multiplication to some
other problem
but these reduction techniques are very
simple in a sense so let me show you an
example
what you want to compute let's say is
two by two matrix multiplication which
is basically given
uh eight numbers you wanna compute
uh evaluate really four polynomials over
these
variables but let's say i can solve some
other problem p
that maybe has more variables and more
it has
more outputs so i want to be able to
embed matrix multiplication into this
problem
and the types of embeddings the type of
reductions that
all of the laser method applications do
they remove some outputs and remove
some inputs of this problem p and turn
it
into the matrix multiplication problem
what does that mean
in this case over here i will remove
these two variables
x 3 3 and y 3 this will remove this term
and i will remove this output over here
and all of a sudden
i get all of the four polynomials that i
wanted to compute for two by two matrix
multiplication
as part of p so you can think of setting
these variables to zero and ignoring
this
output and plugging all the uh all these
variables
in all the other respective places and p
will compute matrix multiplication
okay so i will give it to you in a
tensor form now so you can see what the
tensor form of this looks like
you want to compute this tensor the two
by two matrix multiplication tensor
and but you you have a rank bound for
this tensor
which is some a little bit more
complicated it has
one more z variable and two more one
x and one y extra and what i want to do
now in this tensor set some of its x
y and z variables to zero to get this
one
so i get rid of x y three three and i
get rid of z z3 i set these two
variables to zero
and i get exactly this answer this is
called
zeroing out the tensor p into this
matrix multiplication tensor
with this notation two two two zeros out
from p
so a very simple lemma says that if you
can zero out the tensor p
into q then the rank of q is at most the
rank of p
and the reason is that you can take any
rank decomposition of p
set the appropriate variables to zero
and you will get
a rank decomposition of q so it's
exactly the same rank so the rank
doesn't
increase and so if i can zero out some
tensor into a matrix multiplication
tensor
then i can also apply the previous bound
on omega which is three times log base
the product of the dimensions
and now it's the rank of p over here so
it's a way of
uh upper bounding the rank of matrix
multiplication so this is zeroing out
and this is what all of the indirect
approaches do
all right so actually the laser method
is a little more complicated
so it uses the zeroing out and
it actually reduces not matrix
multiplication tensor but
direct sums of them into not
particular tensors but powers of tensors
and the ten powers of tensor and tensors
have to have special structure
so i'll go into more detail in all of
these three
so first on the next slide i will tell
you how schoenhage
in 81 showed that you can reduce matrix
multiplication
to computing direct sums of other matrix
multiplication tensors
okay i will explain this then i will
also explain how
if you have a bound on the rank of
tensor t
then you can also get the boundary rank
of its nth power for some definition of
power
and this uses recursion and the laser
method does this step over here
it converts direct sums of matrix
multiplication tensors into powers of
small tensors and together when you
compose all of these
you'll get a reduction from matrix
multiplication to some other tensor
and you get if you have a good algorithm
over here you get a good algorithm over
here
so i'm going to now go over the the left
part then i'll go over the right part
and at the end i'm going to talk about
the laser method
okay direct sums
here i'm going to define a direct sum so
let t be some tensor like this one over
here
i can create two copies of this this
tensor
basically by renaming some variables but
it should look the same
for example x 2 2 x 2 y 2 z 2
plus x 2 y 3 z 3 is a copy of t
which is a real name 1 into 2 and this 2
into 3 and so on but when i take the sum
of the original tensor and this one i
will have
variables that appear that are appear in
both copies so this is just the sum
in the direct sum of two tensors uh the
variable sets are completely disjoint
so this this copy of t
and this copy of t have different
variable sets this is the only
difference between direct sums
and and regular sums
so shen hager showed that if the direct
sum of k
copies of some matrix multiplication
tensor has
a small rank then you can bound omega
by essentially getting the same
expression as if you were working with
only one matrix multiplication tensor
except now you get to divide the rank
by k so this is very useful because
sometimes you can show
that the rank of k disjoint copies of a
matrix multiplication tensor
is actually smaller than k times the
rank of the original tensor
and because of this you actually get
better bounds in omega so
schoenhage showed this so now we're
going to use that
so in our picture before what we have is
a reduction from n by n matrix
multiplication to this direct sum
so that if you can bound the rank here i
get a better algorithm for such
objects you can bound the omega over
here
with the correct uh dependence on r ms t
and k
all right so so these are just joint
couples right
so now i'm going to define what the
power of a tensor is so i can talk about
this part
over here okay
so this is the chronicler product so
let's say we're given two tensors
they're polynomials over two different
variable sets
x y z and x prime y prime z prime i
actually didn't put the extra primes
here because it becomes unreadable but
you can think of the primes being here
so s and t are just polynomials with
these coefficients
and their chronic product is just the
product of these polynomials
except the variable sets are merged
so you take the product of polynomials
and the variable sets of
s tensor t are just
pairs of x variables one from
s and one from t pairs of y variables
one from s and one from t
and pairs of z variables one from s and
final t so you take the product of the
polynomials and where's the x variables
which are now pairs
well the y variables and the z variables
they're all pairs this is the croc
product you can use the product to
define
a power of the tensor which is basically
the natural thing multiplying the tensor
by itself n times
now notably because uh of the way we
defined it
now the x variables of the nth power are
just n tuples of variables
of the original tensor and the y
variables are n two poles of the y
variables and so on
so you just get these larger and larger
variable sets
two important llamas is that if you take
the first one is if you take two matrix
multiplication tensors
and multiply them under the chronic
product
you get a matrix multiplication tensor
with a product of
of their dimensions and this is exactly
it this
exactly corresponds to this blocking
idea
that i told you about you can view
an a1 by b1 times a2 by
a2 b2 matrix as an a1 a2 matrix with b1
b2 blocks
right so this is exactly what this
corresponds to
and the second dilemma is that the that
rank
is submultiplicative under this product
so
the rank of a product of two tensors is
at most the product of the ranks
and that's very useful uh when when you
uh
tensor of tensors so a nice thing about
this right is
the rank of the nth power is at most the
rank
of the tensor to the nth power but
sometimes actually can get much smaller
the rank of the tenth power
could be much smaller than the nth power
of the rank
this can you can one simple example is
two by two matrix multiplication that
it's tensor
uh the rank of the two by two matrix
multiplication is seven
uh and but the nth power actually its
rank is into the omega
right something like that which is not n
log base 2 of 7. so
sometimes the rank of the nth power can
be much smaller
and this this is why people define the
asymptotic rank
the asymptotic rank is basically you
take the tensor take the nth power take
the rank and then the
nth root and take an end to infinity and
you can this can be much smaller than
the rank of the tensor itself and so and
this is used in matrix multiplication
algorithms very very
often okay so
back to our picture so
we said what this is we said that you
can uh shane hager reduce n by n matrix
multiplication to
independent copies of n of matrix
multiplications with different
dimensions
and now we can use recursion uh
from the previous slide to reduce the
nth power
to to the tensor itself this basically
just means if you have a bound on the
asymptotic rank of the tensor
of course you'd also have a bound on the
asymptotic rank of the nth power as
r to the n and now all we need to do
is reduce from this one to this one and
this is what
the laser method does
so if we can do that for large enough m
s and t and k we can get a really good
bound
in the matrix multiplication exponent in
terms of this little
r over here so what the laser method
does
it takes these tensors t they have
special structure and uses that special
structure to be able to
get this tense the nth power in in it
zero out a lot of variables and get
a big disjoint sum
direct sum of the tensors that have the
same dimension
and then you can apply this technique to
get omega
so so it's a very specific technique
for how to zero out the variables over
here
if you have special structure in order
to get a bunch of matrix multiplication
tests
so oops
yes so now um i'm going to talk about
the special structure right
so imagine a tensor okay
it looks like this is some polynomial
and what i'm going to do
is take the variable sets of the tensor
the x variables the y
variables and the z variables and just
partition them
in some way okay so x is
partitioned into l parts x1 up to xl
y is partitioned to l parts y one to a
yl and z is partitioned into all parts
okay so we've just partitioned the
variable is nothing smart
and now we get to define a sub tensor so
for every choice of a part
x sub i of the x variables y sub j of
the y
variables and z sub k of the z variables
we can define the tensor that contains
only those
triples x a y b z c that re
that appears these respective parts so x
sub a
repairs in x sub i y sub a and y sub j z
sub c and z sub k
okay so this is just some sub tensor and
what we've really done is we've
expressed the tensor
as a sum of subtenses for every choice
of a part here a part in y or a part in
z
we have an associated tensor when you
sum them up they're completely
disjoint their triples are the joint but
the variables are not
and the sum is t we haven't done
anything smart
we just partition stuff and re-express t
as the sum of a bunch of sub-tensors
now if these sub-tensors happen to be
matrix multiplication tensors
what we've actually done is expressed t
as a sum of matrix multiplication tenses
so we seem kind of close to what we
wanted to achieve what we wanted to
achieve is to take
t or some power of t and get a sum of
disjoint matrix multiplication tensors
ones that don't share variables
these guys over here could share
variables but
it's still on we're on the way there so
we have to get a partitioning
of the variables so that the sub sub
tensors we get are matrix multiplication
tensors
by the way this can always be done
for example you can put exactly one
variable in each set and then like
this is one of these triples and this is
a
one by one by one matrix multiplication
tensor but such a
decomposition is not very useful what
you actually want is these
matrix multiplication tensors to be
bigger than one
one by one by one and this is this one
of the special structures you need for
the laser method
to give you something non-trivial okay
we've partitioned the tensor
fine so i'll give you an example
just so we're on the same page here's
the copper's made winner grab tensor
it's actually pretty simple q is some
number like five
and it's just this polynomial over
here's the
coppersmith when the graph tensor with
parameter cube
why is this tensor useful and
interesting the reason is that
coppersmith vinograd
showed that the asymptotic rank of this
tensor is q plus two what's interesting
about q plus two
well the number of x variables is q plus
two
x sub zero x sub one from up to x sub k
and x
x cubed plus one so x cube plus two x
variables q plus two y variables cube
plus two z
variables so actually this asymptotic
rank is actually optimal
because that's basically the number of
things you have to compute
and if you have such an optimal rank
asymptotic rank expression for matrix
multiplication since the number of
variables there is n
squared we will be getting an asymptotic
rank of n squared which would give us
omega equals 2.
so if we want to get omega of course 2
we should probably be embedding matrix
multiplication and reducing it into a
tensor like this that has
optimal asymptotic rank so this is one
of the reasons why this is used
but anyway let me show you the
partitioning that people use for this
tensor
for the x variables you stick x sub zero
and
x big x zero x one up to x q is
put into x one and x cube plus two
x cube plus 1 is in x 2. so
x 0 and x 2 have only one variable and x
1 has q
variables and you do exactly the same
for the y variables and the z variables
and now what you've expressed the
coppersmith vinograd tensor as
by the sum of these tensors
zero zero two because q plus two n is in
z two
t zero two one whatever zero one one 1
0 1 and so on so it's the sum of these
tensors
but notably these are all matrix
multiplication tensors
these ones over here are not very
interesting because they're just
multiplying a scalar by a scalar and the
output is just one output
but this one over here this one over
here is
actually an inner product because you
have
a single output z sorry
z zero there's a single output and what
you're outputting is the sum from one to
q
of x i y i so just an inner product one
q
one right and this one's q one one and
this is one one q so these are
non-trivial matrix multiplication
tensors and this is
uh and this is what it's used now if we
wanted to
get zero out some variables here
and get matrix multiplication just a
single or
a few disjoint matrix multiplication
tensors out of this thing
you wouldn't be able to get too many of
them maybe just one
because if i zero out x zero it will
kill off
both of these terms if i zero out z
i it will kill off this one so no matter
what choices i make i won't really be
able to get more than one of these
over here so instead
what the matrix uh multiplication
laser method does is it doesn't zero out
the tensor itself
it takes an nth power as i mentioned
before
and zero is out there because there
there's more freedom
okay so let's take a large power
remember t is some tensor like the one
on the previous slide which is constant
size
and it's expressed as the sum of sub
tensors t sub by j case
and all of them are matrix products when
you take the nth power
you will be 10th power of the sum of tij
k's to that power you open up the sum
and you actually get a sum over n2 plus
t1 up to tn
where every one of these t sub i's here
is one of the t sub i j k's that you
made the t
into so you get a sum over
products t one up to t n where
uh each one of these has a is a t sub i
j k
and there's l choices for for i j and k
and there's
um anyway so that you have uh you have
this
now we assume that t sub i j k is a
matrix problem
and each one of these is one of the t as
a by j case and so it's a tensor product
of
matrix products and which we said is a
matrix product
so this sum is also a sum of matrix
products just really really big ones
depending on n so we've expressed the
nth power
as a sum of matrix products
but what we really want is a disjoint
sum
of matrix products that all have the
same dimension
and these don't have all the cell the
same dimension unless the t
i j k's have the same dimensions so
what we're going to do is actually zero
in into uh
some of the these terms that have the
same dimensions as matrix
the way we do that is as follows so you
take in any
one of these terms over here recall each
of the t sub
c's over here is one of the t sub i j
k's that we expressed t
is the sum of and now we're going to
associate a distribution alpha for with
each of these terms each of the
products these are what is this
distribution
it is just the fraction of times for
every ijk is a fraction of times that
this
term has a t sub i j k in it
so if the term none of the t sub ps over
here in the product
is t sub i j k then alpha h k will be
zero
if a third of them is t sub ijk this
will be
a third and and the sum of our over all
the ijks is one
for every any particular term so every
term has a particular distribution over
the ijks
that it it's induced on it
so why do we care about these
distributions at all
all right well the point is if we take a
bunch of these products over here that
have the same distribution
alpha they're actually products matrix
products of the same dimensions
why is this well let's take suppose i
have
uh some t i j k that corresponds to a
matrix product a times
b a by b by b by c as a
abc matrix multiplication tensor and it
appears t
times somewhere over here and p by q
cubed by r appears u times in some
number
in some places then when we take the
tensor product we'll get
a matrix product that is isomorphic
to with the uh to a product with
dimensions a to the t
times p to the u b to the t times q to
the u and c to the t times activity
right these are is going to be measure
and it doesn't matter where
in the product you get a b c is it here
here here doesn't actually matter as
long
only the number of them matters so the
distribution
uh which gives us the fraction of times
these tijks appear
completely determines the shape of the
matrix product that you get
so now our goal is going to be to pick
some distribution
alpha the best distribution and
get rid of all the terms that don't
correspond to that distribution
and what i'll get then is the sum of
terms that have
that are matrix products of the same
dimension and after that i will have to
get rid of some of them so that i can
get a disjoint sum
things that don't share variables
all right the goal is pick a
distribution zero out variables in the
nth power
and you get a direct sum of these terms
they correspond to that distribution so
they have the same dimension
the laser method does this and suppose
somehow it gives us
l such sub changes it gives us l tensors
that all
just correspond to this distribution
alpha
and are disjoint so their direct sum
then
we apply sean hargis theorem which i
told you a while back
and you bound omega by this which is
uh m sub alpha and sub alpha and t sub
alpha are just the dimensions of the
matrix products
for a fixed alpha and it's right alpha
determine
determines them so the only thing that
matters in terms of bounding omega once
you fix
alpha is how many of these subtenders
you get
the more of them you get the smaller
omega you get
so the goal is to pick the best
distribution
so that you get as many disjoint tensors
corresponding to the distribution as
possible
the best number
so we have to analyze we have to have a
method the laser method
that will tell us how many of these we
can get for a fixed alpha
so all right so now i have to take a
step back and see where we are
so we have this reduction for matrix
multiplication to disjoint sums of
matrix products
we have a reduction from the nth power
to
just the tensor we've partitioned the
tensor into the sum of tij k's
then we took the nth power and expressed
the nth power as the sum of these
summons
every summon has a corresponding
distribution that gives us the frequency
for each tijk that appears in it
and then we want to zero out a bunch of
variables in here
to somehow get a direct sum completely
disjoint copies of these
of summons that all correspond to that
distribution
and because they all correspond to that
distribution they all have the same
dimensions
m alpha and alpha and t alpha assuming t
i j k are all matrix products
and then we can conclude omega is at
most this
and then we have to figure out what l m
symbol of n is about for t sub alpha
r okay let's require some math
and oh and then we have a problem what
is our problem
the problem is that we're planning to
zero out variables
but this distribution alpha is talking
about the frequencies of triples
tijk appearing whereas variables
are just a single i or single j or a
single k
so they don't talk about triples they
talk about single things
so we have to convert the distribution
into something
that corresponds to variables
so let's do that we're going to define
the marginals of the distribution
okay for every variable
a variable block i we can do define the
x marginals l
alpha sub i is the sum over all j k's of
alpha i j k so we fix the i and
sum over all the j case so this is the x
marginal you can define the y marginals
and the z marginals
and this just says the fraction of times
in this product that you use t sub p
that looks like uh something that had an
i and some j and k here we don't care
what j and k are as long as the first
one is i
the fraction of times you use something
with a variable from
the ice block so now
i have to take a little another step
back and tell you that
if i take the nth power of the tensor i
want to remind you is
its variables are n2 poles of variables
of the original tensor
so n2 pulse of x variables and tuples of
y variables and n-tuples of z
variables and since we remember we
partitioned the x variables y variables
and z variables into parts
and this is where um the tijks come from
right so
x is partitioned into x1 up to xl y into
y1 up to yl and z is
partitioned to z1 up to zl so the x
variables
and the nth power which are now n-tuples
are actually partitioned into
x sub c one up to x sub c n where each
of these
these c's are buys are from one to l so
uh it says basically in the n tuple uh
the first part of the n tuple which
block is it in the second part which
blockers is in the nth part
and n part of the n tuple which block
of the original tensor it's in so we
have a partitioning of these variables
as well
and now let me tell you what the
marginals correspond to
so the marginals correspond to um
so for every one of the terms that we're
trying to
look at t1 up to tn it uses
x variables from one of these sets so
that the
they obey the marginals so the number of
times
uh we see i in one of the indices here
is exactly alpha i times n so the
fraction of times we see i
here is alpha i so this is what the
marginals tell us
so every term here has some margin of
zero base
and the laser method zeroes out
variables according to
whether uh if they do not have the
marginals that we desire
we pick at distribution alpha compute
the marginals and then
zero out variables that don't obey them
and when we do that
we will get a sum of terms so that they
obey the marginals
all of their variables have exactly the
correct frequencies for every block
and in particular any term
that actually corresponds to our actual
distribution that we want
will survive but there could be other
terms at the survival as well
that obey the marginals but they're not
according to our distribution in some
cases this can happen
in any way once you do this the laser
method converts these into a direct sum
after you have things that obey the
margins
so how many terms can you possibly have
in such a direct sum
well okay we're zeroing out entire
variable sets
and uh if we want two of these sub
tensors
to not share any variables then
they we we want them really to not share
the same variable sets so
the number of disjoint sub tensors can
be no more than the number of variable
sets we have
because they have to have
distinct variable sets in order to be
disjoint
but the number of variables says that
obey the marginals is exactly this
multinomial coefficient it says
the number uh out of these n possible
indices in the variable sets
we need alpha one of n and alpha
one times n of them to be one alpha two
times n of them to be two alpha l times
one of them to be l
so the number of possible things that
actually obey the marginals is exactly
this multinomial coefficient
and because the number of disjoint
subtensors we
can possibly get by zeroing out entire
variable sets
is at most the number of variable sets
we can never get
more than uh m disjoint
subtensors so if we want to maximize how
many disjoints of tensors obeying the
marginals we get
we we should try to get m and so
this is what the laser method achieves
but only under certain conditions
it achieves the maximum number you could
possibly get but under
under some conditions the conditions are
like this
so remember the marginals they actually
define the linear system
over the actual distribution entries so
for every fixed
i the x marginal alpha i is just the sum
over j
k of alpha i j k that's just how we
define the marginals
um but this gives a linear system for
every fixed choice of the marginals
uh you wanna you can define what the
distributions that match the marginals
are
using this linear system and if it so
happens that this linear system has a
unique solution
then the laser method guarantees that
you will get the maximum possible number
of disjoint
tensors so actually achieve roughly m
if this linear system has a unique
solution
so basically what happens is
that the laser method gives you the
maximum number of disjoint things that
you can get
as long as the marginals of the
distribution you're picking
actually determines the distribution but
even if they don't determine the
distribution they give you something so
the laser method gives you something
so in particular it will always give you
a disjoint sum of
roughly the maximum possible number
of disjoint sub-tensors that are good so
they're consistent
with alpha but if the distribution is
not determined by the marginals it will
also give you a bunch of
extra sub substances which are a lot of
noise so let me
let me give you an example of this so
what it will give you is a bunch of
uh sum a disjoint sum of tensors
uh let's say tii means that it
this tensor uses the i variables of
x variables the i y variables and the i
z variables
so that all of these have disjoined
variable sets right the
for the ones that use the first x y and
z variables
don't share variables with the one that
uses the second ones
but then you also have a bunch of these
tensors here that are based on other
distributions that
uh obey the marginals and they could
share variables with some of these
disjoints
like this t253 we'll share variables
with the second
t22 here and the fifth one over here and
the third one over here as well
so we have to get rid of all this noise
because this is something we don't want
and
in all the work up until now getting rid
of this noise costs a significant
penalty
so that actually the number of these
joint subtensors is much much less than
n um and in particular this is what's
what's going on suppose that you have m
good sub tensors and
s times m extras of tensors s is
something big
right then we have to get rid of the
extra subtensors and when we get rid of
the extra ones we're actually getting
rid of the good ones as well
the old approach guaranteed that you can
do it and still get get m over s good
subtenses remain
what we do is actually show that you can
get m over square root of s
of tensor's remain remember s is large
what does this mean for omega so omega
had this expression over here
and l was in the denominator so if you
plug in
l equals m over s s goes up here
s is big okay with our new approach this
becomes square root of s
so the bound on omega will immediately
decrease
okay so from s you go to square root of
s and this is really how we get an
improvement in all the approaches you
you have you get this
mathematical expression and then you
have to go and run optimization software
to figure out the best distribution
alpha so that you optimize uh
omega over it right each distribution
gives you these m sub alphas and sub
alphas and r sub alphas and so on
and you figure out the best distribution
but here uh we knew immediately they
will get a better omega
even without running any software
because we we knew that this s is always
really big
so it will give us a better bound so one
slide on how we get the improvement
so uh remember we have m good subtenses
and s
bad ones s times them by ones the red
ones up here the bad ones the
green ones are good the old approach to
getting rid of the
the bad ones works like this you
repeatedly
pick some one of the good subtensors
that shares variables with
s extra ones and there is one so that
because
on average you know there's s times n
bad ones and m good ones so there is one
that shares
variables with order s extra ones and
then
for all the ones that it shares
variables with you pick some
variable that doesn't appear in the good
one you want to keep
and set them to zero now for every
variable that you set to zero you will
be getting rid of one of the goods of
answers remember they're completely
disjoint and have distinct
variable set so once you kill off let's
say uh
the second x variables that you kill off
t22
here but you won't kill off any others
so for every
every variable every bad sub tensors you
you kill you kill also um one
good one so you remove or order s
that one's for everyone you keep and
therefore
uh you get m over s good subtenses
remaining and you kill off everything in
red
this is just the greedy approach and and
this is what we improve
so how do we improve it well it turns
out that the probabilistic method
suffices
what you can do is pick m over square
root of s
random good sub tensors and uh
work out the math and you can show that
if you
zero out every variable that your random
sample
doesn't use you will with constant
probability actually not constant
non-zero probability you
you will actually kill off all the
balance so you will remove all the
extras of tensors with non-zero
probability and still have m over square
root of s
of the good ones remain and it turns out
that for a very large
family of tenses this squared of s
improvement is actually optimal you
cannot get
more independence of tensors over here
while also removing the bad ones so this
is our improvement
how useful is this improvement well it's
it's all it's applicable as long as your
tensor partitioning is big enough and it
applies
for any one of the powers of the
copper's and window grab tensor after
the eighth power including the best
bounce uh copper's moving at 32 you can
go to the 64th power we didn't do it but
if you go there you also improve the
boundary omega
you could also apply it to any future
tensors as long as the
uh partitioning is large enough to
warrant the
extra steps that we do as i mentioned
it's the optimal for a large class of
tensors
and since the laser method has other
applications uh this improvement would
have other applications as well
so some other applications are in some
other questions about tensors and then
extremocombinatorics such as the capsid
problem
all right and one final slide
what's next as you see there's
diminishing returns over here we're
getting
smaller and smaller improvements
and in fact this is this is formalized
there's a reason why
a line of work on barriers for copper
window grad like tensors
for the tensors we look we use so for
example
if you use the same tensor we've been
using uh
even with a slight generalization of the
laser method you will not be able to get
better than 2.3725
so maybe you can make this eight into a
five but that would be it
unless you change the method or the
tensor
also if you take a vast generalization
of all the methods that we have
and you still apply it on the same
tensor you will not be
better you won't be able to get better
than 2.18 i would love 2.18
so i would totally go for it but still
you won't be able to get to two
if you wanted to get to two what do you
have to do you have to completely change
the tensor you cannot stick with
copper's monogram like tensors
i don't exactly know which types you
should
take or you should abandon the laser
method and
variants of the laser method all
together and in addition also use
tensors that don't
for which the laser method doesn't apply
as we know
we know that if the laser method applies
it will if it's possible to get two it
will give you two
so if you want to get two you have to
change the method
and the tensors so that's next
uh there's a lot of work to be done how
to do this
anyway thank you and sorry again for the
technical difficulties
thanks thanks very much virginia
so um uh let's let's take a couple of
uh questions and i guess we're gonna be
splicing the video later so
um cameron asks in the chat about the
connection between
uh tensor rank and matrix multiplication
um you know is it possible that there
are
omega equals two algorithms that um
don't arise with tensors having low rank
um so
i don't i don't see the question but
yeah what a
from what i understand it's asking
whether this sort of method of going
with tensors and rank representations
whether this is the best you could do
for matrix multiplication and the answer
is that if you stay
in the arithmetic circuit model where
your question is how many
operations over the field you need in
order to compute the
to to do the matrix multiplication then
this is the best the rank method is the
best
um yeah so this is a theorem
if you change the question and you say
uh just in general what you don't care
exactly about the number of operations
but you also allow
data structures and other stuff and you
convert the field into like other
algebraic objects and do something
completely different that
that doesn't forward in the arithmetic
circuit model then other things could be
possible
uh so this is one of the reasons why
people look at combinatorial matrix
multiplication algorithms
boolean matrix multiplication where you
allow other stuff
but so far these methods haven't been
able to even get close to
what we can get with the rank bounce
and uh just look at the q a
stream there that people have posted
one one question is about the
probabilistic method does it only
guarantee existence
yeah it guarantees existence yeah
um if you of course if you want to get
a the actual algorithm then you could
stop it stop the thing at some
nth power where n is actually not
an arbitrary variable but a large enough
constant and then you can
kind of brute force over the possible
things you know that an
embedding exists and you can find the
embedding and then
that will be your algorithm you'll lose
a little bit in the exponent but you can
do it
and uh i guess a couple of people asked
the obvious question if you had to bet
is omega equal to
if i had to bet i say is bigger than two
but i'm in good company strousen thinks
it's bigger than two so
yeah of course everybody else thinks
it's two so i don't know
fantastic well thanks very much virginia
that was a really fascinating
presentation
um thanks to everyone in the audience
also um
uh please join us for the next talk in
in the breakthrough series on august 5th
um you want to see chandler's going to
be speaking on
an almost constant lower bound of the
isoparametric coefficient in kls
conjecture
so we hope to see you there thanks very
much